how's it going red my name is welcome
back to the moon wearing quite the
pickle right here I have to charge this
backpack with balls are you following up
with this yes charge the backpack with
balls then we click the backpack and
then we prepare in the backpack and then
we go back in time I know it that may
not seem it I can make this is also easy
say I'm a genius I'm getting a lot
better at these but you probably solved
it too so okay I'm sorry
let's go back in time that's just Ellie
not just do it take the backpack back in
time I want to find out what happened
like John what did he do what did John
Doe if so I don't know it's I know a lot
of people like how come Peter is not
crying it sounds like I I know I feel
like it's sad but since I don't know
anything yet what happened I don't feel
like I can kind of just I don't know
everyone this wood is with it it's
different job I guess they're talking
about her condition her disease I don't
know what that is her syndrome just
because she and I shared the syndrome
doesn't mean we share the same head but
you must be able to help somehow
everything was okay at first but now
she's even more aloof than before okay
so she was crazy before she taught he
told them at least like crazy but even
when we're in the same room she's never
really there it started to take a toll
on me I just don't know how to take it
anymore
well I can't speak for her but many of
us do long for connections though being
able to articulate it is a different
story
sorry I don't read perfectly it's it's
cuz I'm not American I guess just
because she struggles to express it
doesn't mean she doesn't feel anything
she's still there right sometimes you
just have to fate I have faith that she
cares that it's complicated that's
pretty difficult to do day in and day
out
I know wait but why do you seem nor so
normal Izzie I mean don't you have the
same condition for one I was diagnosed
when I was still young with effort it's
not impossible to acquire a guise of
social norms systematically it's Jo she
pretends that she's normal when she's
not but you know what I both envy and
pitted razor why me I'm an actress
because I've been doing it all my life
not only on stage but offstage and that
practically every moment I've gotten
good at it because acting is the only
option I have it's the only way for me
to be north that's what I said
genius PD strikes again but rather she
never did that she remained an outcast
and refused to learn to step against it
I don't know if it was by choice or by
limit where the bravery or cowardice
[Music]
there are days when I just can't stand
faking it anymore and then I realize
it's too late there is a bell that
people know is all an act and the real
me has long become a stranger I think in
the end I just n beard it's not a fight
that I both had the same syndrome but I
still don't know what it is ha I never
met a moment with it before then
technically you still haven't met one
this isn't part of our business let's
move it's always like that
oh it's not part of our business well we
gotta talk to her I guess Oh John is
coming over that's Hyde right he can't
see us anyway
what can we do here
but John get y'all done anything new
today no what are you rereading there
the Emperor's New Clothes
I love this when I was young that's
pretty good story still do huh
of course just for different reasons
okay when I was a kid I loved any more
of Sheree's house anymore I know your
mother gave you a book from as a wedding
present
yeah yeah that was one odd wedding
present I guess I was pretty obsessed
with it when I was a kid
ooh the tone is changing why haven't you
read them since ah hmm
I saw them they're collecting dust in
the garage
well I just drew out order my guess
I mean dark children's books
what's wrong with reading children's
books I don't know they're for children
they're comforting okay
I suppose so no I think I'm going to get
this one okay you go go you go and get
that while I investigate the world would
be a lot more beautiful if people just
remembered faces what okay I'll take it
stop John what don't telephone John but
what about David he's my favorite
character uh I don't know what are they
talking about anymore have you read it
no yes really sort of uh oh do you know
what animal David's main cover more oh
[ __ ] let's Google at the Cobra I didn't
change oh yeah a Cobra I really wish
they kept the old colors instead of
these plain sheets they were so cool I
feel like the yeah I'm not yours you're
not mine be my aunty Valentine
hey river this one is not that corny
River and we got all the balls the
question is what do we charge them um I
don't really know so she doesn't like
corny stuff and John is really corny I
guess or maybe she likes it I don't know
freakin girls man maybe haven't talked
to this John so let's do that up don't
tell apart when I talk to you John
alright to be as hard
Rachel grizzly Jake Tiger Barker gorilla
David Cobra Cassie wolf why okay I guess
Cobra was in there so oh just wondering
you could have just googled it
I guess I was a clue what what about now
can we talk to them
perhaps I should read read the master
all I can barely recall anything from
that Siri do it John just do it not for
me but forever okay I have no idea where
I'm gonna put this oh there it is
alright let's go back in time Bruce we
go what back game time back in time back
in town only I can click on it
prepare wait the one back another pass
on oh [ __ ] this looks difficult Oh
click this yes what did that do put this
like this oh [ __ ]
I messed up didn't I well it was one
more than idea god dammit well that's a
nice book right there
[Music]
down let's activate the momenta of the
Emperor's New Clothes and I want to know
John what did you go oh what is this
where are we now oh he's young now maybe
this is when they met ah no no no it's
too early I mean uh everyone's leaving
already but I just got here seems like
seems to happen - you had a lot of pie
she's so mean oh go save your childhood
jabs for the insecure let's look at this
let's look at this picked olives
I see laughs Amash but where's the moon
we way that's the cornice remark he made
all night don't you mean the cheesiest
Bunch
Wow good job dr. watts good job all
right let's go north it's I don't know
what else I'm gonna go oh we're still at
the yep are you doing it looks so young
and sweet is it too early to talk to you
nah
but it's going on here
[Music]
do you feel any different
now that we got they got married a child
yeah I mean now
why do you
yeah actually yeah
what is it life
it's just deaf
just the responsibility
responsibilities
do you like the name Anya
I guess it's a pretty name yeah would
you like to name her Anya
[Music]
why does she have to name the lighthouse
Idaho
I understand I don't but this is better
[Applause]
yeah and yes a good name
hey come with me
[Music]
yes at that way
they're going all the way up do it
make a time lovemaking time baby-making
no oh ha ha
this can't be a good idea I'll probably
trip and fall
don't worry just follow other dancing
god damn it
it's a late
[Music]
that's how you get the ladies oh my ass
that's not how you get the ladies John I
think you step John you're sorry
come on let's try again wait to break a
mood oh my ass ah they dance all right
but it's like it that is love right
there ladies and gentlemen
to promise to love and comfort to honor
and to keep in sickness and in health
for as long as you shall live
I do and do you take this man standing
before you to be your lawfully wedded
husband to promise to love and comfort
to honor and to keep in sickness and in
health for as long as you shall live
yes by the power invested in me I now
pronounce you husband and wife
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
mr. and mrs. wilds
[Applause]
[Music]
that is back jack there's outside
ah the wedding oh yeah what did you
think it was I'm just bad at wedding
that's all fluids tend to escape from my
eyes I didn't know you were that
sentimental oh did I say my eyes I'm at
my mom and buy fluids I mean both fluids
and solids
that's a lovely image thanks Neil god
dammit come on let's get let's find a
way out of here all right all this
happiness and joy is really puffing you
up too huh no I just don't like watching
people make mistake what
geesh whatever happened to us take it
moment by moment yeah exactly
girl it's like so sweet they're like
talking it oh we're going through your
body sorry about that I guess we got to
find the platypus
it's always the platypus or the olives
or the some rather random up up there's
the wedding dinner not that many people
I'd say it's a pretty bump
oh I better go see how your aunt is
doing all right mom tell her thanks for
coming I will I'm so proud of you Joey
ah Joey oh that's my grandpa's name he
passed away before I was born
my calls made my abiding my neck how
come you never told me about it
because I rather you call me John white
is this a clue AK not to nod the
centromere a little what do you have
against those anyway I made you sure
talk about your grandfather all right
what no I don't whatever you say all
right I will have to end this episode
here breath
beautiful beautiful like a favorite of
India Bruce helps out a lot
subscribe to become a broad today and I
see you whenever I squeeze my nipples
okay that they let it [ __ ] all right
I can't take it anymore
best be joking right now
oh you [ __ ] we're actually fine we're
not fine Starbucks Abba Dabba